-The committee investigating
Donald Trump's coup attempt
on January 6th
is preparing to hold
its first televised hearing
in primetime on Thursday,
and Republicans, predictably,
are already lying about it.
For more on this.
It's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Republican paranoia
about voter fraud
has gotten so unhinged
that they're now accusing each
other of stealing elections.
In Georgia, for example,
Trump and his allies
targeted ultra-conservative
Governor Brian Kemp
for the sole reason that Kemp
refused to single-handedly
overturn Joe Biden's
win in 2020.
Kemp easily defeated his
primary opponents last month,
including a Trump loyalist
named Candace Taylor,
who came in third and lost to
Kemp by more than 70 points.
But MyPillow CEO --
and your -- and your pillow.
[ Laughter ]
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
looked carefully at the data
and came to
the unfortunate conclusion
that something fishy
is going on.
-Brian Kemp they put so high up
that they wanted --
they didn't even want --
"Why, he got 73%!
How could you take
his other votes?"
Well, let me tell you,
everybody,
we have preliminary evidence
that Candace Taylor,
for every single vote
that Kemp got,
he took her -- got their votes,
and then Candace got 5% back.
-What? He took her votes
and then she got 5% back?
Are you confusing elections
with credit cards?
"You get 5% cash back
on every vote
and double points on travel
and restaurants
and concrete pillows
when you choose Capital One.
Capital One --
what's in your wallet?
No, what's in there?
What's in there?
Is that a ballot in there?
Are you trying to smuggle votes?
What's -- Tell me
what's in your wallet!
I'm making
a citizen wallet check!"
Trump himself did the same thing
before his preferred candidate
for Senate in Pennsylvania.
Dr. Oz won
the GOP primary there.
-Fewer than 2,000 votes
now separating TV Dr. Mehmet Oz,
who has a slight lead,
and former hedge fund
executive David McCormick.
Today, Trump urged Oz
not to wait for all the votes
to be counted.
"Dr. Oz should declare victory,"
the former president said.
"It makes it much harder for
them to cheat with the ballots
that they just happened
to find."
-Of course, Trump and Oz
teamed up to scam people.
They're like the Jordan
and Pippen of con artists.
Or maybe the Jordan
and BJ Armstrong.
You're no Pippen, Oz!
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised
if Dr. Oz started using Trump
to sell his bogus diet pills.
He'd use this same picture
for the before and after.
And Trump's supporters
would still say,
"You can't argue
with the results."
This is where the big lie
has led them.
According to Trump
and his gang of weirdos,
anyone they don't support
is cheating.
This is the lie, of course,
that led to the violent
coup attempt on January 6th.
And as the committee
investigating that coup attempt
prepares to hold its first
nationally televised
hearing in primetime
on Thursday,
you'll never guess which
supposed the news network
has decided
not to air the hearing live.
Well, I mean,
of course you'll guess,
but we're going to show you
the clip anyway,
because, like, we had to,
like, find it and edit it down
and it was just like really
hard work.
So take a look.
-Fox News making
a programing decision.
It's sticking with its
primetime lineup on Thursday --
Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity.
This is instead of showing
the January 6 Select Committee
hearing concerning
the Capitol Hill riot.
-It doesn't surprise me that Fox
isn't airing the hearings.
Fox is news the same way
"The Kardashians" is reality.
Just once, I'd love to see
an actual reality TV show,
something called, I don't know,
"Man Quietly Eating a Cinnabon
Because He Missed
His Connection at LaGuardia."
It's the best reality show
set in an airport
since "Former Mayor Shaves
While Eating Soup."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, they're having an issue
with the machine.
We have a machine
that helps the jokes.
[ Laughter ]
Hey! [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Machine!
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry I crossed you,
Machine!
It's not a surprise because Fox
constantly says
the opposite of what
the hearings will say.
The committee will lay out
the truth of what happened
and Fox will lie.
It's that simple.
The hearings will say
January 6th
was a violent insurrection
fomented
by an outgoing president
who nearly pulled off
a detailed plan
for an attempted coup
to unlawfully cling to power
that would have installed him
as an unelected autocrat
and destroyed
American democracy.
And Fox will say it was just
a pro-freedom patriot party,
where everyone peacefully
toured the Capitol
like they were
on a school field trip
having to find items
their teachers gave them
on a worksheet.
"I got podium!"
[ Laughter ]
In fact,
the January 6th investigation
has already provided us
with one bombshell
after another --
from the revelation
that Trump ignored pleas
from friends and family members
to stop the violence
as he watched it unfold on TV,
to various detailed plans
written by multiple Trump aides
to get Mike Pence
to overturn the results
to a series
of shocking revelations
that make clear Trump put Pence
in direct physical danger.
-This stunning new report
in "The New York Times"
says that a top aide to
former Vice President Mike Pence
warned the Secret Service
that President Trump
could turn
on the vice president,
and the aide feared
for Pence's safety
on the eve of the Capitol riot.
-So, when
his Secret Service agents,
including one of them
who had -- was carrying
the nuclear football with him,
were chased out
by these neo-fascists,
and they ran down
to some still undisclosed,
mysterious place
in the Capitol.
He uttered what I think
are the six most
chilling words of this
entire thing I've seen so far.
He said, "I'm not
getting in that car."
-"The New York Times" reports
January 6 Committee testimony
shows former President Trump
approved chants about
hanging former Vice President
Mike Pence.
In last year's attacks,
some rioters started chanting
"hang Mike Pence."
Well, according to the report,
White House Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows testified
he told colleagues
Trump agreed that
maybe Pence should be hanged.
-"Maybe Pence should be hanged."
Do you think Pence
is more offended
that Trump expressed support
for the idea of hanging him,
or that Trump
did it the same way
my aunts order appetizers?
"Should we get the order of
mozzarella sticks or two orders?
We're going to need the energy
if we're going to
hang Mike Pence.
Should we, though?"
[ Laughter ]
So the vice president's
chief of staff
warned the Secret Service
that the president
was putting him
in physical danger.
The vice president then refused
to get in the car
when the Secret Service tried to
whisk him away from the Capitol,
and the president
casually suggested
that maybe his own
vice president should be hanged.
I feel like even Aaron Burr
would be like, "Dude, cool it,"
and Aaron Burr shot a guy
while rapping.
What's that?
Oh, the rapping
didn't actually happen?
That was just that...?
So they just did that
for the Broadway show?
That's going to break my kid's
heart when I tell him that.
Republicans like to pretend that
instead of looking back at 2020,
we should be focusing on issues
that matter to average
Americans, like gas prices,
even though they're the ones
who are obsessed
with the 2020 election.
And also they don't have
a serious plan
for dealing with gas prices.
-This is the biggest scam
on Thursday
perpetrated
on the American people
since the Russia collusion hoax.
This is total nonsense that
you're going to see on Thursday.
And the problem is they know it.
The Democrats know people
do not care about this.
They're desperately trying
to get people to buy into this.
But the problem is,
people are more concerned, Sean,
with the super high gas prices.
-What we have found with
one-party rule of Democrats
taking over the House,
the Senate and the presidency --
they use the power to go
after their political opponents
instead of bringing down
gasoline prices.
Today, it has now doubled
since the gasoline price
since President Biden
has taken office.
Are they going to have
any hearings on that?
-You know, I actually would
like hearings on gas prices,
but I'd love for Congress
to haul the big oil CEOs in
to ask them how much profit
they're making,
which I'm guessing
isn't Kevin McCarthy's idea.
He'd probably just call
an actual gas pump to testify.
"Sir, you claim to be both super
and premium.
Is that not redundant?
I yield the floor
for your answer."
Look, we'd all rather be talking
about other stuff,
but you guys are the ones trying
to destroy American democracy.
You're like a bunch of arsonists
who burned down a house.
And then when the fire
department shows up, you say,
"Um, shouldn't you guys
be working on
this year's sexy calendar?
[ Laughter ]
Get your priorities straight."
Now, luckily, there's more
than enough time for them
to put out the fire
and pose for the calendar,
because we all really want
that calendar, and fun fact,
I auditioned for it one year
and they told me I was in,
but then they gave me
a fake month
that wasn't even in the calendar
called Junevembruary.
[ Laughter ]
We did that joke mainly to see
what kind of upper body
Graphics gave me.
And once again...
they [bleep] me.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans do this infuriating
thing where they're the ones
threatening to dismantle
American democracy.
And when we try to do
something about it,
they say, "How come you're
not focused on gas prices?"
Also, by the way,
they don't have a real plan
for gas prices either,
other than drill more,
which would do very little,
since fossil fuel companies
already have thousands
of unused permits
for millions of acres
of federal land
they're not even using, and
additional energy production
wouldn't hit the market
for months anyway.
There isn't some
miracle solution here.
You can't just give your car
a patented Dr. Oz gas pill.
If Republicans
were really serious
about focusing on other stuff,
they'd be talking about urgent
crises that affect real people,
like the cost of living crisis,
wealth inequality,
health care, education,
climate change,
food insecurity,
or child poverty.
According to a recent survey,
nearly half of families
with kids
who used to get
the expanded child tax credit
can't afford enough food
after the program
ended five months ago.
Our political system
has seemingly just forgotten
about that,
but it's outrageous
and unconscionable,
especially in a world
where one dude
can just flip over
his couch cushions
and find $44 billion
to buy Twitter --
a dumb website that's only good
for posting Wordle scores
and fighting with anonymous
accounts named WallyFan8275678,
who keep tweeting stuff
and be like,
"We need more Wally on the
show."
-That's not me, Seth.
-What? I didn't even say
was you, Wally.
-Okay. Good.
Because it's definitely not.
-Oh, well, if it's
definitely not,
then I'll just respond
to that tweet
and your phone definitely won't
get a notification.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
Whoa, did you get a text, Wally?
-Yeah. Uh, oh.
No. It's just
my local animal shelter.
They want me to...
They want to take me
for a volunteering.
-[Bleep] out of here.
[ Laughter ]
Get out. Stop it.
Stop everything you're doing,
Wally!
Sorry about that.
What was I talking about?
Oh, right. Child poverty.
You proud of yourself, Wally?
You interrupted child poverty.
Which should be getting
a lot more of our attention,
but Republicans
don't really care about that
or any other issue
affecting working people.
They just use those
very real problems
to deflect from the fact
that they tried to stage a coup
to install Trump
as an unelected autocrat,
and if they get the chance,
they're going to try it
again in 2024,
which is why they're desperate
to cover up what happened.
Every news network will be
closely covering the hearings
except, of course, for Fox.
I'd be shocked if they showed
their audience even...
-5%.
[ Laughter ]
There's been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.